we have the right if we get pregnant we  have the right not to be mothers right  yeah should men then in the name of  equality have the right not to be  fathers their wallet their choice they  can sign off on child support why no  because if you had sex with a woman you  fully know well that one of the  consequences is that you will fully like  pregnant her and you have a child so you  have to look after child as that's your  responsibility your sperm your  responsibility okay you can't run away  from that okay I don't understand why  people in their mind think it's all  right to run away from the child that's  a child you're leaving them with so much  trauma having no like Dad and everything  that will leave them with severe like  ideas of how they think about men  because I'm not talking about my  perspective I've seen people's  perspective with no fathers they act in  a certain way with people that have a  father like in contrast with people who  have a father and it's not right